foreign
hey George camel here co-host of the
Ramsey Show welcome back to another
episode of the best of the Ramsay show
this episode features some especially
fun calls around money and relationships
you know money fights deception couples
not being on the same page entertaining
stuff trust me you don't want to miss
this one
Justin is in Pittsburgh hi Justin
welcome to the Ramsay show
okay John thanks so much for taking my
call really appreciate it sure what's up
uh yeah so the the retail for my call is
uh currently 28 years old I've been in a
relationship with my girlfriend for the
past two years and I'm thinking about
taking that relationship to the next
step uh here pretty soon yeah she is a
veterinarian who just graduated uh last
year is going to bring about 350 000
worth of uh student loan debt into uh
our marriage Lord congratulations
wow so I guess I guess I really just
wanted to call I've been you know new to
the show and new to you guys but I've
been doing date like things for the last
uh three or four years and was just
curious what your advice would be in
regards to how we can plan to make those
repayments uh once we we get married as
well as how we prioritize that
um against other large life um you know
purchases such as a house you know
Vehicles things along those lines
foreign
man how much debt do you have outside of
that 350 how much debt do you are you
going to bring into this relationship uh
nothing completely debt free
um you know I've been shaving and
Investing For for quite some time I have
about 21 000 in cash uh sixty thousand
dollars in uh my traditional uh savings
plan our tsp and um uh 401K yeah and
then as well as about uh investor
portfolio of a hundred and ten thousand
dollars okay that's helpful what do you
do what do you make
um so apparently this year I just got
back from a nine month deployment so I'm
gonna make somewhere around 107 uh this
year and then on track to make like 135
uh next year
projection wise
okay
and so obviously your military thank you
for your service
appreciative all right here's the thing
um the number one cause of divorce in
North America money fights and money
problems money stress
you are walking into
a a mess
she has made an unbelievably large mess
and you guys have as part of your
pre-marriage counseling have got to
because you have an unusually large mess
you've got to go unusually deep
in your relationship and in your
agreement on what our short-term and
long-term future looks like
uh if she says uh if she's going to play
and I have no idea okay but there's kind
of two ends of the spectrum here if
she's going to roll up her sleeves and
be blue collar and go oh my God we've
made a mess we're gonna dive on this
thing we're gonna we're gonna fix this
thing I'm gonna work like a maniac I'm
gonna uh work with every sick puppy in
an 800 mile radius as a veterinarian I'm
gonna work my tail end off and I'm gonna
make 200 000 a year while you make a
hundred thousand a year we're gonna put
your hundred thousand out of your
Investments towards this and we're gonna
clean this stinking mess up in two years
now you've got a woman you can marry
if she's like oh well you know it might
take us 30 years and I don't really want
to work that much
I went and spent 350 000 to become a
veterinarian but I'm not going to
Veterinary much
run
run yeah no she's she's definitely
fantastic and uh you know oh I know
she's fantastic that wasn't what I asked
so is she all in brother is she in on
the work part
she's she's in on the work part uh you
know she definitely
when when she looked at the the grand
amount uh you know our heart kind of
pounced a little bit I definitely think
that it's uh something that's on a tip
of her mind um but you know with with
our goals what branch of the military
yes
uh Navy sir yeah what do you do
uh well so I'm in the the reserves
actually so um I'm a supply guy in the
Navy and then uh I work in the oil gas
field as a program manager so gotcha
okay this is a program to be managed
that's exactly what this is and here's
the deal the deeper you sacrifice in
hours of work and in lack of Lifestyle
the faster this mess goes away the
faster this mess goes away the higher
the probability is that it's going to go
away and you don't crash in the middle
of it and the faster it goes away
obviously the faster you can go become
very very wealthy and you can back your
hours back down where you can breathe
again but both of you are going to be
working like maniacs and you're going to
live on nothing and you're going to
drain every account that's not a
retirement account you're going to throw
it at this after the honeymoon and you
guys are living on a budget that's beans
and rice rice and beans and she's
working all the time
until she cleans this mess up
okay and then one more thing I want to
throw at you can you got capacity for
one more
absolutely John all right
you agree to this and you walk down that
aisle this is not going to be you verse
her
this is going to be you with her right
and so I know especially I know guys who
like to flex and say well if you hadn't
and if you once you're in y'all are in
this together and so the shame part's
over then it's just you all about y'all
digging and building it's not about her
digging something out and you just
standing there watching it as she digs
right we're all in this together is that
fair
absolutely it's awesome that's awesome
good man the problem becomes ours and
the opportunity becomes out that's right
both and and listen here's the thing you
guys will come out of this so freaking
strong oh man and you will be you will
your relationship will be so strong and
your your character will be so strong if
you bust up into this but if you screw
around with this this is a mountain and
it'll bury you guys
that's what I'm concerned about yeah so
you got it's got to be like game on and
all her friends come out of vet school
are going to get new Lexus and they're
gonna give you houses and all that stuff
they can all jump in a creek man because
they're dumber than rocks
they're gonna they're gonna make a mess
I'm telling you man you're gonna have to
be so laser focused but the beautiful
thing is that's going to knit you all
together like a because you're fighting
a common foe a common enemy and you
you're knitted together it's gonna it's
gonna do stuff in the DNA of your
relationship that uh the easy times
won't bring to your relationship
absolutely so it's a huge opportunity if
you approach it right and you're both
fully committed to it but it's a huge
problem if either one of you are going
to be half buttoned this thing so you're
like blaming her or she's like going to
be a little princess or whatever with a
vet coat on I mean you know no you got
run
run away you know that's the thing if
that's the case but I don't think that's
her I I think she's special and um and I
know you are after talking to you yeah
so I think you guys can do it but the
this is the parameters this is the
boundaries by which this huge mess
becomes a blessing to your family
generationally because you'll be telling
the grandkids with the with the uh uh
marshmallows on the end of a stick
someday 50 years from now well back in
the day when your granny got out of edge
school we didn't have nothing
and we had to work and we had to sweat I
had my that's why you're here on the
back of this mountain and we owned the
whole stinking mountain and you're doing
your marshmallow here kid this is your
story man and Grandma had her arm
halfway up a cow's you know but we got
it paid off we got it paid off
you could have never gone there we'd
have been okay hey man if I'm grandma
that's what I'm pulling up
and you went and played in your oil and
gas I had to stick my eye to go shoulder
deep to get this debt paid off but I did
it
but I did it
oh you are wrong that's awesome oh
well that's it I mean you got you gotta
have the story it's like when you're
getting out you're driving a junk car
you're driving a hoop do you need to
give the hoop to your name and you need
to take pictures of it yep it needs to
be on the wall never forget you're the
hoopty it's the never this is why we're
here no more because we did this yes and
that changes everything and there's
nothing wrong with telling those stories
that's what families are made of that
are that have substance to them it's
good stuff and you're getting ready to
build one of those Justin proud of you
man Kristen is in Charleston South
Carolina hi Kristen what's up
how are you better than I deserve how
can we help
hey so I
ate um 21 000 profit from it and um this
is the most money I've ever had in my
whole life and I want to put it directly
into my savings account but I just
wanted advice on how I can continue to
be in a good financial position and not
be tempted to spend any of it
congratulations how old are you thank
you I'm 25. how long have you owned this
house
since 2017. all right you did good I can
hear her Joy through the phone yeah it's
exciting good for you a nice 21 000
check send me twenty one thousand I'll
get joyful like all day long yeah that's
good so uh where are you gonna live
well right now
um I'm renting an apartment with a
roommate
um but I plan Once the lease has done to
um buy my own house again once the what
is done
Once the lease is over with uh with the
apartment starting next year I plan on
buying my own house again
okay so you weren't living in this house
oh yes I was living in the house how
come you sold it
um I I unfortunately I separated from my
fiance
um so the money was split in half and
balanced thing with a roommate
um and until this lease is done
um
I would like to buy my own house next
year I love it okay and so
um well here's what you do you you uh
you can just keep it in a bank account
that's all you need to do nothing fancy
uh ask for your ask your local Banker or
your credit union to open you a money
market account do not connect it to
overdraft protection on your checking
account do not connect it to your ATM
card
do not have access to it unless you go
to the branch and pull money out that
will keep you from accidentally
impulsing when you see a couch on sale
on the weekend
right
and if you you build some protections
and make it a little bit hard to get it
get to it does that make sense
yes sir that makes perfect sense yeah do
you understand if it's connected to your
checking account you're going to have a
tendency to I want to buy something I'll
just keep writing checks right
right and if you if your ATM the same
way so just protect you from you which
is what you're concerned about but the
good news is you're already aware of
that so you're very unlikely to make
this mistake
how long have you been separated
um about two months okay so I would set
up with your roommate is this a friend
of yours
yes yes it is okay come up with some
number because this grief is gonna wave
over you like being out at the beach
okay
and it will wave over in different
seasons and at weird moments you're
going to be walking in from somewhere
after having a great time and it's just
you're gonna feel like someone just
dropped one of those heavy blankets over
you okay I want you to have some sort of
agreement with your roommate that you
will check in before you make a purchase
over X dollars
is that cool and that would be your
accountability partner through this
grieving process because I don't want
you to use you're going to have 21 000
taking account and like Dave said it's
going to be so tempting just to to go
get that dopamine hit and feel better go
to the bank and you're just gonna have
to get a new car or have to get a new
designer oodle dog or some kind of
something go on some vacation whatever
it is have have an accountability
partner that you got to check in with
I'll give you the number anything over
300 you have to check in
how's your relation how's your
relationship with your mom and dad
okay you might also have that agreement
with them then
okay and that's not you not being an
adult that's just somebody that loves
you that's kin to you right that you can
check in with that's not that you have
to ask your mommy that's not my point
but my point is the same thing John's
doing is giving you accountability and
so um okay one last thing I don't get to
do this very often would you mind
helping me with something
yeah sure would you talk to the audience
out there because I catch a lot of grief
when I tell people not to buy a house
with people they're not married to
because crap like happened to you
happens
would you talk to people out there that
are thinking about making the same
mistake you did when you bought this
house with this Goob
well um my advice would just be
[Music]
uh you want to spend the rest of your
life with and make sure my advice is to
get married that would be my advice yeah
because you thought you were going to
spend the rest of your life
all right I was 20
. I think it would have been a lot
easier if I was married
um
and
that would be my advice yeah don't do
don't buy a house with people you're not
married to that's what I tell people all
the time and people sometimes that are
your age make fun of me because I'm an
old grandpa but that's but it's also I
have met with over the 30 years of doing
coaching I've met with thousands of
people in your situation and not you
know the good news is the house sold and
you're able to make money you made money
and you're able to split the money and
you're able to get away from this
problem and get out of what a lawyer
would call a partnership yeah a general
partnership with no partnership
documentation and so it turned out okay
in the end you made it out with your
skin intact and made a little money but
uh to go with the Heartbreak you have to
go with this disposition of assets as if
there's a divorce and yet there is no
legal track to run the thing on the last
thing you want to do in your grieving is
math right yep that's the that's the
last thing you want to do man yeah
that's exactly right whether you don't
have life insurance you don't have
any number of things man yeah thank you
Christian thank you Kirsten Kirsten I'm
sorry for for sharing that but it's this
is the reason it it doesn't always turn
out like you think it's going to so get
things in the right order don't buy a
house until you're married with someone
you are not married to
um and so again she got blessed and got
out of it without a problem and I'm
happy she did I didn't I didn't want her
to be punished or something like that
but I am uh she said you know 21 years
old yeah
and um and like we talked about earlier
in a previous segment you got it all
figured out when you're 21 right
and you're 41 and when you're 51 and
when you're 61. I have and I I if I have
on a much smaller scale I know you have
man talking to folks in that same
situation who are trying to split debt
oh it's harsh it's it's a it's Mayhem
yeah you couldn't you couldn't have a
that conversation beforehand which led
to this you know breakup trying to
figure out who's going to take what debt
and how you're going to split when you
bought this on that credit card and you
bought that and the house we have to
write a check for it remember that time
you used the mustard dude it gets
contentious and messy yeah it's it's
it's like a it's like breaking up with
your roommate oh because you are yeah
yeah Roland is in Oregon hi Roland how
are you
I'm good Dave how are you better than I
deserve how can Ken and I help
well my wife and I have been doing the
baby steps uh our entire marriage about
16 months we've always been on the same
page and recently uh we did a zoom call
with a financial advisor that she had
before we met he helped her set up a
Roth IRA and
um she wanted to introduce me and he
advised us
um to be fully funding her 401 and also
be saving for a home
um while we're paying off student debt
and so now she wants to throw your plan
out the window and I want to keep going
like a gazelle to pay that debt and I
don't know how to get her back back on
the plan I don't either
yeah
well um she thinks now that that you
your your steps are kind of a broad
stroke for people who are making poor
decisions and uh doesn't really fit [ __ ]
they're designed for people like her let
me take a stab at this how much how much
debt do you have right now
134 134 000 made up of what
student debt all student loans yeah any
of that any of that hers
no sir it's all yours how much do you
make how much do you make
I I'm making none right now I'm a
full-time Seminary Student she makes
340. she makes 340 000 a year
yes sir and Europe doctor yeah
she is a a surgeon yes
okay that's gonna hurt my plan because
here's the stab I was going to take and
that is that she's got to see that while
this guy has made this advice to her
that you still got this debt and you're
and you're it's going to take so much
longer to pay it off doing it his way in
her way and you're going to actually
make progress faster part of the problem
Dave I think is we've got a a she's the
full-time income she's the oh the only
income and she's making big money and
she doesn't feel it doesn't hurt her
enough the debt doesn't hurt and Rowan I
don't know how to help you let me tell
you what you're experiencing yeah 30
years of me coaching people in finance
the worst
people the worst category of people
handling money are medical doctors
as a category they suck at handling
money worse than pro athletes worse than
anybody
and the reason is is that they're very
very smart intellectually
and they make the mistake of thinking
that that translates to finance
you know they don't know beans about
Finance but they have an intellectual
arrogance
and they go make stupid butt decisions
and they firmly believe with all of
their intellectual arrogance that
they're making the right decisions and
it's the worst category now not all
medical doctors are that way but it's
stereotypical I mean I'm in Nashville
with country music artists some of them
do some stupid butt stuff some of them
are brilliant with money uh I mean I
meet everybody from actors to pro
athletes to whatever over 30 years the
worst category are medical doctors they
are perpetually in debt and they're
perpetually underperforming in their
wealth building because of their
intellectual arrogance and that's what
you're running into and I don't know how
to fix that because now she and her
little financial advisor who between the
two of them don't know beans about money
have made a decision so I really I don't
know how to help you sir how long before
you get out of Seminary and start
working it doesn't matter I mean well
I'm just 340 000 they can pay it all off
and one year yeah but I mean unless he
convinces instead the financial advisor
kept her is keeping student loans around
like they're a freaking pet
I got she got 140 000 of student loan
debt she makes 340 000 if you can't pay
that off in a year you're a wimp that's
ridiculous it's ridiculous that this
advisor takes this poor a stance and
leaves this couple in debt this far you
should be sued for malpractice as a
financial advisor for doing that that's
just asinine
just asinine but they're going to do it
so I honestly don't know how to help you
that's what you're coming up against
though and um truthfully some humility
on her part is in order
and saying you know what I really don't
know anything about this area I just
listened to this one guy
and you know he disagrees with the other
guy and so Matt maybe now we can have a
discussion but no no no don't doubt Dave
Ramsey's a knuckle dragger and his ideas
are primitive and they're broad Strokes
how about the broad stroke your idiot
financial planner gave you
there's a broad stroke for you so I mean
just just God aggravating his crud so I
I honestly don't know how to help you I
really don't know how to convince
someone in that situation what to do I
think you're going to experience pain
before you do and I think you're going
to experience that she makes a lot of
money and you're not going to get the
best use of it as long as you're
following this idiot that she had on the
phone well the one thing we can do is he
can if she's not going to get on board
then once he starts working he's going
to take all of his salary and yeah now
we're telling people split their money
apart and that's going to split couples
apart That's not healthy for their
relationship well no well I'm not well
hold on because I don't want to confuse
the honest I'm not suggesting that they
split their money I'm saying well they
have a split plan her plan and his plan
well but he's not going to not pay the
debt off yeah well he's got to pay it
off he is if he goes along with her yeah
so I mean you're not gonna pay it off
for 30 years if he goes along with her
yeah that's true I think he's got to sit
down and show her if we pay this off
look how much more we can invest how
much quicker that's the only shot he's
got is it just a little she's married a
Seminary Student so maybe we ought to
read the Bible
there is borrower is slave to the lender
that's true how about that let's try
that one yeah I just thought the only
thing is Dave I just don't think you
were clear enough with him and I don't
think you showed enough emotion I feel
like you mailed that I feel like you
mailed that call in
no I get it it's frustrating it's a
tough situation because this is a
marriage well it is and
you know he's getting bullied well okay
so I'm going to bring this up and I
don't and if you send a hate mail I'm
not going to read it so don't send it uh
oh go ahead and send it we use it for
kindling yeah that's true we do we use
it for the fire pit Outback
um how much this has nothing to do with
her being a woman him being a man but
how much of this is the fact that it's
his debt student loan debt and she's the
soul bread winner I think that's a big
factor in this isn't it it can be and
the fact that she doesn't think he's got
a vote yeah that's what I'm getting yeah
this is something should have been
handled before you get married I agree
that you know this is a messy
psychological deal giving her 100 of
their marriage she's gonna out earn him
yes unless he has some kind of
ridiculous career in Ministry that that
most people don't have right I mean a
pastor's income is not going to keep up
with the medical doctor's income and 340
000 a year in 99 of the cases so this is
going to be an issue for 50 years oh big
time if that's if that's what's really
marital counseling yeah just like any
other problem with it be parenting hey
she wants to discipline the kids this
way I think it's this way this is a big
issue this is marital counseling is what
this is this is the shot to get somebody
objective in there in the middle let
both of them hear each other out out and
they've got a they've got a fight on
this as a married issue this is just
like any other major issue in your
marriage in fact maybe bigger let me
explain to you what I'm talking about
because some medical doctors are all mad
at me now because I didn't call all of
you I said the category okay it's a
stereotype right which means that some
people aren't right but
here's the thing
the people that have the most trouble
with money are oftentimes the most
that have the best and the highest
intellect
because they overthink it they think
it's a math problem and personal finance
is only 80 percent Behavior 20 head
knowledge Bobby's with us in Columbia
South Carolina hey Bobby welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hey Dave uh and it's George right uh
this is Ken today
with me yesterday
George is nicer than Ken yeah yeah
I can't I can't argue that he's the
nicest person on the planet he is you
know he's nicer than all of us that's
good stuff good personality qualities
right there right yeah okay sorry about
all that how can we help
um basically you know recommended to you
uh previous boss and a long time friend
of mine uh you know very humble man uh
man of God Brandon Blake thank you very
much I hope you hear this
um I'm uh kind of in a pickle right now
Dave I'm 24 years old I'm a young father
I got a three-year-old it'll be three in
December absolute Pride enjoy my life
and my biggest form of motivation and my
wife and me were still together
um I'm currently living with some
relatives and I've been here for about
seven months uh my wife was working
full-time and just switched to staying
at home to watching our son while I work
full time I just got a really nice job
the best one I've had since I've been
working in the professional field 401K
offered pay time off bonus structure
things of that nature I'm in a very
weird position though with how to take
you know I'm very young with my
professional career I want to set up my
foundation with investing properly as we
stand right now my debt I only have
about twenty thousand dollars of debt
seventeen thousand dollars in student
loans about two thousand dollars in
medical bills how much do you make
um 35 000 a year um if my bonus comes
out the way that it should this next
year it'll be at 40.
working 40 hours
40 hours a week yes sir um your baby's
how old
uh he'll be three in December December
6.
what was your wife doing before she quit
she was working as a cake decorator for
Lowes Foods
um and has since lost her position uh
mainly due to it was during covid so it
got pretty hectic
um and right now she's just staying at
home and interestingly enough she also
has an international business degree
four-year University from Rollins but
she doesn't have any direct experience
working in the field not even in a job
like a starting job that would even be
relatable to that yeah what's the pickle
that you're in you've given us a lot of
details what's the pickle my pickle is I
have two options right now
um you know eventually inevitably I want
to move out my mom and dad are generous
enough to love me a little allow me to
live rent three um the only thing I'm
having is living expenses and a couple
other payments
um but I need to figure out you know if
I mean obviously saving money is what
needs to happen
um but where to put that money is the
question no there's not any question
you're you're broke and you're living
with your parents you need to pile up
some money in a savings account and get
out of there
yeah yeah you don't need to start don't
worry about investing and don't start
your 401k you're broken in debt
and you guys have got to do something in
this household to increase your incomes
so since you're only working 40 hours
you need an extra job and your wife
needs to start doing some freaking cake
decorating while she's at home with a
three-year-old
yeah no you're right you're not wrong
Dave
um and I guess my next question is you
know to make my the smartest decision
possible
um you know my credit score is pretty
good at 700.
um my thought process was getting at
either a mortgage on a house no you're
broke
you need to go get a one bedroom or two
bedroom apartment as cheap as you can
get and you need to pile up cash as much
as you can and you need to be working 80
hours a week and she needs to start
working 30 hours a week when the kids
down so she can get some other income
coming in you guys need to get your
income up 50 to 70 000 immediately and
start paying these debts off and get out
from under your parents roof yesterday
yes sir my question is though in regards
to the rent with renting I mean as you
know rental properties the money you put
in goes into a hole you don't get it
back honey you're broke
you're a renter
you don't buy a house when you're broke
you are broke and in debt you make
thirty five thousand dollars a year and
every three year old and you're 24 years
old you don't go buy a house right now
this house will be a curse to you you're
trying to mix long-term
issues in with your short-term emotions
and you need to get the short-term stuff
taken care of you need a big pile of
money for an emergency and to move and
to get out and you guys need to get your
incomes up and then you begin to attack
the debt and when the debt is gone you
build an emergency fund a fully fund big
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses then we'll start talking about
saving for a house you're not buying a
house for three two to three years from
today if you're wise
it's just hard Dave because you know
with rent it's not hard
an additional it's not hard you're 24.
you'll be 27 when you own your first
house it's not hard at all yeah somebody
has told you that renting is throwing
money away and you can't get past that
thought and it's simply not throwing
money away for two years when Stacy and
I moved here to join Dave this was the
move for me we took two years in rented
because we wanted to make sure we were
going to the right place we wanted to
make sure that we were going to lock in
and and dive in and we had to save money
to be able to get the kind of house that
we felt that we wanted to get we weren't
throwing money away that's a false
narrative and you're not hearing the
wisdom and the truth here that Dave just
gave you the baby steps work every time
but only if you get this mindset out of
your head that renting is wasting money
renting is buying patients while you're
too broke to buy oh that's good you're
buying you're buying time and honey
you're you're so broke you live with
your parents
that's how broke you are you don't need
to go from that to owning a home you you
need to get out get the debts paid off
build up an emergency fund build a
foundation for your young family slow
your butt down you're okay you got
plenty of time hey if you enjoyed this
episode click here to watch the next one
where you're going to hear all about the
wild world of cryptocurrency